what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday the 22nd of the month
spring is here the joint is brought to
you by draftkings listen
i know
football is back this weekend college
football is back but so is ufc 266
volnowski against ortega and nick diaz
against robbie lawler schilenko you got
a tremendous card and draft cooking
sportsbook the official sports betting
partner the ufc is there has a knockout
offer for you on this weekend's fight
draftkings is offering all new customers
a dollar
and free bets if just better dial in any
fight on the main card
no matter what happens you get 150 in
free bets did you hear what i [__]
just said
150 in free bets and it's only the third
week of football better dolla on any ufc
fight draftking sportsbook will give you
150 in free bets [__] tremendous mma
ain't for you no worries draftking
sportsbook has you covered they got
great odds and promotions on football
college football baseball the baseball
playoffs are coming draftkings is safe
secure and reliable download the
draftking sportsbook app today use promo
code joey to receive 150 and free bets
instantly when you place a dollar bet on
ufc 266
promo code joey to receive 150 in free
bets for a limited time only at
draftkings sportsbook app you got to be
21 older place of bet new jersey indiana
pennsylvania colorado west virginia if
you're legal draftkings is for you new
customers only the winnings get paid out
and psych credits now restrictions do
apply see draftkings
sportsbook.com for details now if you
have a gammon farm i want you to take
care of it this might not be for you
call 1-800 gambler if you're in indiana
call 1-809 with it
but if you got all your [__]
cylinders running download the draftking
sportsbook app and win some guitars
today if betting is not for you download
this fantasy app and let me tell you
something the sportsbook has a
tremendous casino blackjack poker
[__] roulette you name it listen
they're safe reliable
and they're convenient and they pay
draftkings sportsbook app download it
right now the joint is also brought to
you by
zip recruiter listen to me places are
reopening again movie theaters
restaurants you want a job every place
is hiring right now
millions of jobs will be be filled as
businesses keep reopening how do you
hire people fast and the best people zip
recruiter try it for free at
ziprecruiter.com
show it you have nothing to lose here's
the difference with zip recruiter you're
just not posting a job and waiting for
resumes from joe schmo to come in zip
recruiter has fancy technologies that
finds the best people for the job
four out of five employers who post on
zipper crew to get a quality candidate
within the first day that's tremendous
right now you could try ziprecruiter for
free
absolutely free at
ziprecruiter.com that's ziprecruiter.com
joey try it for free
just by going to ziprecruiter.com
joey's zip recruiter
the smartest way to hire since we're
talking about business i got more ways
to save money for your small business or
your large business you ready stamps.com
did you hear me stamps.com if you got a
small business you know there's nothing
more valuable than your time stop
wasting it on trips to the post office
stamps.coms make it easier to mail and
ship right from your computer at home
you save time and money with stamps.com
since 1998
stamps.com has been indispensable tool
for nearly 1 million businesses
large and small they bring the services
of the us postal service and ups
right to your door all you need is a
computer and a printer
there no special supplies or equipment
required within minutes you're up and
running print official postage from any
letter anywhere you want this ship any
package
and at stamps.com new rate advisor tool
you can compare shipping rates and
timelines to easily find the best
options for you if you're not with
stamps.com you're slipping save time and
money with stamps.com there's no risk
cocksmokers use promo code joey to get a
special offer that includes a four-week
trial plus free postage and a digital
scale no long-term commitment to
contracts just go to stamps.com right
now click on the microphone at the top
of the home page type in joey j-o-e-y
that stamps dot com
promo code joey never go to the post
office again
the joint is also brought to you by
uncle joey let's get this party started
right now [__]
i'm more confused than [__] here on a
wednesday morning
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
so
what's happening you bad [__]
uncle joey here welcome to uncle joey's
joint wednesday the 22nd
of september i'm [__] excited today
for the last two years i started working
on the many saints in newark
in uh march or april of 2019 and here we
are
september 22nd of 2021
and the movie gets released tonight i'm
very [__] excited what doesn't get
released
tonight's the premiere the release is
next friday
october 1st i cannot tell you
how [__] relieved i am i just want
this to be over with i want to watch the
movie
with the people i shot it with most
importantly with my wife
uh a few of my friends bought tickets i
i you know i was against it but
a few of my friends paid all the dough
for tickets uh they could have just
waited and saw the movie
for 12.50 you know but they want to be
around
and hobnob with people whatever
uh i'm excited i thought about the work
i put in to get this this was a 23-year
uh
journey for me
concluding with this movie
i took this movie and i was so proud of
doing it that
i ended up moving the [__] jersey i
was so proud you know i was very proud
of me for what i had done you know
today's podcast the guest is samson
mokulikili i don't know what his last
name is he's from [__] samoa
or he's hawaiian whatever he's a great
kid you know
everybody always says to me you know
joey thank you
for doing what you do you inspired us
and stuff and i never get the chance
to return that favor you know to people
you know like to say to you believe it
or not
you inspired me by putting that video up
or whatever
when i first got to many saints in
newark the first couple days you know
there's always a doubt when you're on a
project
for the first couple days there's a
doubt until you get into the rhythm i
had to get into david chase's shooting
style and into his mental
psyche to understand what was going on
you know when i and i wasn't struggling
or anything to find it i just went on
the set and i didn't really know you
don't know
you know mike said something to me today
about he was thinking about putting the
video up and he goes i just didn't know
you know you just don't know you know
um
[Music]
how to do things so
sometimes there's somebody there you
know when you go to something like uh
you ever go have surgery or something
you go to the hospital and while you're
sitting there you're a little [__]
scared you're kind of like out of your
comfort zone but you start talking to
somebody and that person tells you like
i've done it before it's fine and also
and you feel a lot better that's what
i'm saying like sometimes there's always
somebody there
to ease your anxiety
when i first got on this film i had i
knew john bernthal and i knew a couple
of the guys you know lightly from
different projects but i didn't really
know anybody you know i didn't know
alessandro i didn't know corey and i
didn't know samson and samson was just a
young kid he was there to play
big [__] but
his enthusiasm
his eyes you know his work ethic
inspired me like i went back to the
hotel room after like the second day i
had worked with him and i'm like [__]
i got to pick up the pace a little bit
you know what i'm saying these [__]
kids are savages which is good it wasn't
that i was doing bad at all or i
wouldn't know what i was doing i just
everybody needs that little push once in
a while you know it's like when you open
up a [__] jar that's stuck like the
other day you got pickles or something
you're trying to [__] open it it
don't open and all of a sudden i go to
like my grandmother and my grandmother
was like
and she takes it right off sometimes you
never know who could do that you know
and like you're like graham you're
strong no she just held it right or
whatever i didn't know what i was doing
you know i knew what i was doing
but i was kind of like out of it it was
the first two days three days on the set
and just watching samson his enthusiasm
was [__] contagious
and i could tell his enthusiasm was
rolling over on other people you know
because we were all talking in between
scenes and stuff and he was just a great
kid and the thing that made him more
special was how young he was like
you want to go up to them and go do you
really want to [__] get into this
[__] right now you know you should be on
chasing [__] skirts but you know what
this is great
this is great this is what you do i wish
i would have started acting at 21. i
wish i would have started half the
things i started at [__] 18 or 15
but i was too busy [__] snorting coke
and you know jumping up and down and
thinking i was cool
you know now i'll know for the next time
when i [__] make a comeback i don't
know i'll probably come back as a
[__] lizard or some [__]
and won't let me do the [__]
opportunities i want to do
but it's funny man being an actor
like while i was talking to samson
on the interview i was thinking about a
story i'm going to tell you guys how
[__] fired up i was in 2003 like
i really wanted to do this i really
wanted to succeed
it wasn't money it wasn't that i wanted
to hang out with boats with [__] and
you know you know girls gone wild and
that that's not but if you know anything
about me that's not who i am i didn't
want to go to a bar i didn't want to you
know that's not what i wanted i just
wanted
to find a little bit of success with
something
when i say success i mean something that
makes you happy
something that makes you proud i've
never been proud of anything in my life
i quit basketball my mother died i quit
high school i quit everything i started
i quit this was the only thing i [__]
stuck with and i stuck with it because i
loved it and there was a way for me
to contribute back to society to let
society know i was healed i wasn't a
piece of [__] junkie anymore and i
wasn't a [__] thief i wanted to
succeed
i wanted to see my name on the [__]
side of the credits again it wasn't to
to be a millionaire or
you know have a boat or to have a butler
or to tell people what to do that was
never my intentions it was just to
succeed at something just one [__]
time
you know so
for me
robert de niro was my everything you
know today he's a shell of what he was
but robert de niro was everything when i
was coming up you know de niro pacino
you know before that it was steve
mcqueen it was all those guys so my
first big break honestly was robert de
niro's analyze that again it's not an
academy award winner who gives a [__]
i pulled it off
that's all that matters that i
auditioned
i read nobody gave me dick and i did it
i did it
nobody else
you know that takes a certain type of
pride i never used to sit back and smell
the [__] roses but now i am
now i'm seeing what kathryn narducci
said you know
people change you you talk to different
people and heightens your intelligence
sometimes
it heightens your way of thinking you
know but i always had that sense that
you know yeah it's not an academy award
winner but it's a movie you know how
hard that is you know how hard the
process was for me to keep it together
enough to go in there focus and [__]
go in front of [__] somebody not be
nervous
that that's a lot of [__] steps
there's a lot of [__] moves there's a
lot of different pieces in auditioning
but you do it and you [__] uh and
this is what we do but i i still
remember getting analyzed this
and my scene was with uh anthony
lempockley who was at the time was a
great actor i don't know what the [__]
happened to him i just saw him a few
weeks ago he must have gained like 80
pounds like uh
he looks like the guy from gladiator
have you seen the guy from gladiator got
a movie on [__] netflix
holy [__] he's been eating cheeseburgers
for the last two [__] years i mean
i'm no [__] physique dilemma morneau
but [__]
jesus but anyway i'm i'm getting psyched
up about this uh de niro movie and i
can't wait i'm trying to book this is
i'm trying to
book uh
you know i'm trying to book comedy shows
so i'm trying to call the [__] agents
and say listen all the club owners and
go listen i'm coming out on this movie i
think analyze that came out december or
something like that so i was trying to
get dates around it so people were like
you're in the denero movie
come on joey stop bullshitting me so i
had to [__] prove it to these people
that i was on the thing i contacted the
producers they will not give you your
reel
before the film gets released
nobody will give you a reel before the
film gets released you know i don't care
about my scenes now i could care less
i'm not looking
to add things to my acting reels or who
gives a [__]
you know you want to see me watch the
many saints you know that's all i got
for you but
so i needed this reel you know
to book other things i wanted to get on
the sopranos i wanted to get they were
doing a lot of mafia movies big end
high-end mafia movies
so i called the producers they told me
they couldn't give it to me
i called the production house they said
they couldn't give it to me and one day
i'm doing a show in atlanta
this is how [__] weird life is i'm
doing a show in atlanta and there's a
nice little dude there african-american
dude
he's in the service we're talking
and i tell him my dilemma i'm like i'm
trying to get this clip from this movie
and he goes i get it for you
like what are you talking about he goes
listen i got a friend
who could hack right into that [__]
streaming service
and take a piece out for you
i'm like
you're gonna hack
the [__] studios movie system and get
me the reel and i'm like and they're
like yeah we do it all the [__] time
i'm like
all right send me the reel well a week
later
i get an email with the reel and the
phone rings
and the kid goes look at your email i
got you to real like oh thank you i owe
you he goes there's only one problem
it's backwards
because they send it backwards so nobody
could steal it so when you do steal it
you gotta change it around so it and you
know it's like i'm standing here and
he's standing there not in this scene
with cross and it was a [__]
nightmare
so i'm like oh my god i got this [__]
thing
and i got my scene i'm so [__]
excited but now i gotta flip it around
nobody knew how to flip it around i must
have called 20 [__] people
savages nobody could flip it around i'm
like how am i gonna send this tape out
so i finally called this dude somebody
told me call this dude he'll help you if
he can't help you nobody can't
and this dude [__] uh says come on
down bring me the cd
i'd bring him the cd with the thing i
taped off the [__] email you know
i have no idea what i'm doing and the
guy looks at it and he go he goes this
is
this is a property of whatever united or
i don't know who the company was he goes
we can't turn this around we're going to
go to jail i go listen
who gives a [__]
i go you got this boring ass job anyway
the guy lived in a [__] garage i
swear to god the guy lived in a [__] he
had a little cot next to his little
computer and he would just sit there
with his little cat and [__]
dude like nasty things and [__] uh
you know cut videos and stuff all day i
think he was like added a slash hacker
or whatever he's like i can't i'm
[__] scared and i go listen dog you
better [__] do this
because i already told this guy i was
getting it so he did a bunch of things i
saw him hitting computers and cutting
and [__]
transferring to other computers and
he goes you're gonna have to go home i
have to mail it to you
because you know it was on a cd i took
it off the computer put it on a cd
a dvd
and then he was gonna send it back to me
i got all the way home two hours in the
[__] garage i open up my computer i'm
ready for [__] uh the headline
the [__] thing flipped again
like you can't even describe this thing
and it flipped again and separated us
more
so
i said [__] it they're gonna have to
wait till december to get the reel and
that's my [__] story about [__] my
friend hacking into the studios to try
to get my reel and it came out backwards
and [__]
these days
nobody could [__] fix it back then it
was
18 years ago anyway [__] i'm
excited about the many saints in newark
i know a lot of you guys are excited
about the money saints of newark here's
my man samson uh who's playing i love
him in the trailer in the trailer the
new trailer because i think they got
like two trailers out i saw the one
trailer last night during monday night
football and they're like
what do you call yourself [__] i
[__] love that people at home must
have [__] flipped their wigs
let's watch samson i'll see you guys
afterwards stay black
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
who's living life you know look at my
little brother looking [__] younger
you look younger doug
how are you sam
yeah how you doing
yeah putting the pieces together excited
for [__] tonight you know this is
what we all put the work in for two
[__] years ago
living on the streets walking around
every [__] night
eating pizza
you know the whole [__] thing it's
coming to the i'm very proud of you and
i'm happy for you
you know this happened for me at 58. you
know this happened for you at 20
something this is uh
this is the beginning of your [__]
career and how to balance it from this
and people busting your balls and
you know ready for i'm getting ready for
i think i'm ready for it yeah man it's
listen you can't get ready for this
[__] life
you just live it go
you're going to get hit from time to
time you're going to get some [__]
ass kickings but
you have a roast beef sandwich you get
up and you do it again [__] them you
know and you go back and get what
belongs to you like [__] uh
[__] nut and [__] gladiator you know
what i'm saying
he came back [__] missing fingers i
don't give a [__] i'm taking what's mine
how's it going
how's new york looking
it's cool man i uh
it's only like my i think maybe like my
fourth or fifth time here you know when
we came to shoot the movie was my first
time ever so really yeah first time ever
and then we filmed i had
i want to say one or two days in jersey
um and that was my first time in jersey
too so like
that time and then i came back for the
wrap party
um
we had alessandro's premiere for art of
self defense that came to that
and then rishi yeah so i this is
literally like my i think it's like my
fourth or fifth time ever
so i'm always porous when i'm here
i was like you know [__] uh
i was like ho-hum on this movie in the
beginning yeah but you
really
motivated me like that's where
you know it's like when you
it's like when you go join a jiu jitsu
school or karate school or something
they always
the the school will always sell you on
you know the camaraderie and
this and you know you know staying young
like not staying young they don't put it
in those terms they
they say that keeping your mind young
you know it's really important like when
i was looking at this uh website the
other day from the jujitsu school i'm
going to and that had a
thing when you're older you know when
you're older it's good for you to go to
a thing because you stay not that you
stay young not that i'm walking around
with [__] skinny jeans
and trying to be cool with blonde hair
and a streak and [__] tattoos on my
cheek you know what i'm saying like
people try to stay young by looking
young
you know yeah i dye my hair to [__]
shoot [__] and stuff like that but
that's it like i don't you know i don't
wear like a [__]
hat and take pictures of me smoking a
cigarette like all mysterious and creepy
you know that that's not what i'm about
but
just trying to keep your thought
yeah trying to keep your head
and uh when i met you and we started
talking i would see your enthusiasm and
i would go
this poor [__] bastard
he doesn't know
he doesn't know what he's [__] doing
themselves so funny it's so funny
everyone like mostly because you know
everyone on this is that
this is my first thing ever um michael's
first big thing you know his first
feature and he's you know
playing such an iconic character but
it's like us too and then it was a bunch
of vets and it's funny because like a
handful of you guys have all said like
i remember you being excited to come to
work one day and it's like yeah probably
chill out and i was like what man i'm
happy like it's fun like the [__] i'm
making a movie we're making a prequel to
the sopranos like it's like why how are
you not excited to like oh my gosh like
it's just so dope like everything about
it it's so sick like what people
understand is we would have done it for
free oh 100 like i wouldn't have sat
there and [__] negotiated with
somebody like i'll do it for free david
chase directing learning teaching
you know see what the [__] he does you
know i would have done it for free like
it didn't even bother me at first i was
like
the money i got the hotel three weeks
without my daughter
and i was like and it was
in and flew back to l.a in the back out
right yeah i flew out three times i flew
out to l.a
i flew out to milwaukee one time in
minnesota and then i had to fly back for
sunday because i was shooting tuesday
thank god i didn't have to shoot monday
i was [__] beat to [__] up four shows
in theaters and then another flight and
another flight my back was hurting
and then i flew back and i came back and
shot the last seven days maybe yeah and
i think it was fun it was fun for me i
really had a great time
i always had a blast when we were
working i mean it's
i had a blast every day i mean there was
even days where i wasn't working i still
went to the site i saw that i'm like
this [__] is loving it i think
you're going for the free food
because that's the only reason i go to
the set
i came to see you shoot your scene get
the [__] out of here i came for that
steak that free steak they give you a
pedium you got to milk that [__]
pedium you know what i'm saying they
give you 55
you got to put that in your pocket and
[__] you got to take as many cookies
home as you can
the [__] longest yard they had so
much food
today
and
the sopranos had a lot of food too the
many saints had tons of [__] food
but the longest yard had 25 people that
needed to be fed someone said you guys
had like gorillas
wrestlers like you guys have i never
forget the big guy the leap
i'll never forget walking down to get
the van with him at six in the morning
and before he would get in the van the
guy at the restaurant at the hotel would
just hand them at the goal thing
do you know what it was
it was like 15
hard-boiled eggs
he would sit in that van eating
hard-boiled eggs and i could smell those
[__] i would tell him to leap knock
it off with those [__] eggs
you stink terrible what's going to come
out of your [__] is going to be even
worse he was just because they're indian
they love eggs they love hard-boiled
eggs i didn't even put the correlation
together
until years later when my daughter was
in daycare there were these little two
little indian girls that would eat
[__] eggs every day hard-boiled eggs
and you would walk in there and you
could smell [__] in the whole daycare
because i and i go who's [__]
[__] like this that it smells like
an eight-foot man
and they would say little indian twin
girls they were the cutest [__]
things
they were so cute i could have quit my
job i could have quit everything and
just walk these two indian girls into
disney and lived off the 10 percent she
they were twins and there were five they
were my daughter's eight they were
beautiful
but they had kicked to them they were
kicking them they were kicking them
field goals from the 80-yard line they
was thinking up a storm in that [__]
bathroom
but you know that's the whole thing when
you do a movie you're like i'm excited
to [__] eat like if you do a movie
and you don't gain weight you're a loser
plain and simple i'll spit in your
[__] face that's what movies are for
the game
and it's funny because like you know you
have crafty and then there's lunch and
then there's all kinds of different
things and then i remember
i forgot what we were doing but we were
at base camp
you remember this day it was like me you
magaro um
somebody else was there
and uh
it was taking so long and you ordered us
pizza it was
the [__] dude is tremendous right now
bro oh my god we got some pizza from
brooklyn that guy used to fall asleep
there's a guy in brooklyn that has a
pizza parlor i don't know what his
[__] name is he's an old italian guy
and the guy from the green book
was the guy that told me about the pizza
place he was gone nick nick nick was
that that's right so yeah it was me you
nick nick
there was like some there was like
another like a featured action that was
hanging around with us too i thought it
was paulie
was billy there i think it was billy
it might have been billy it might have
been billy
i just remember because we're all just
sitting there and
i don't know where it's like i'm
ordering a pie all right yeah [__] yeah
and the one day we ordered gyros [__]
with [__] me and bernthal
we were ordering food i don't give a
[__] and i you know i was working out
i was but i was eating i wasn't eating
none of the sweet [__] that little truck
that they had that you went in with the
little mexicans that was deadly in there
then [__] were not [__]
around their job was to fatten you up
i think i went over like i [__] off
like seven times in one hour they're
like what do you want this time i'm like
i gotta stop i gotta relax i remember we
shot in brooklyn i just started walking
i went to carvel and i bought [__]
those flying saucers and i gave them to
the girls in wardrobe and makeup and
they weren't [__] nuts
i was giving them reefer and [__]
flying saucers
they were so happy i came back would
just buy i would buy a whole thing of
flying saucers eat one and just give it
to them i think that day that particular
day i ate it with uh
john bernthal and me walked over to
carvel it was right down the corner
where we shot those last scenes
the
yeah yeah yeah i had that i remember one
night we went to eat dinner and then we
had to be two in the morning
and the only thing that was open were
those [__] uh
bars where you smoked that [__] from
the hookah bars and how many [__]
pokeballs are there in brooklyn
everybody's smoking a hookah get outside
and smoke weed you [__]
every [__] hookah dog i went back to
l.a going what the [__] i forgot about
new york that
at two in the morning that could be 30
people to bodega
we would go eat dinner and i remember we
had to go to a school and then get out
and walk yeah remember one night we must
have walked two [__] miles to go get
dinner through fences through yards
down the stairs i'm like what what the
[__] i remember that i remember because
i yeah we had to walk away and like you
know
everyone on this move was so sick so
dope everyone was cool and they were
like oh you guys want to rise or
whatever and i just remember i was like
yeah i we'll take one in breath i was
like nah we'll walk and i was like [__]
i guess we're walking
all right here we go but yeah i remember
that was that was those were
those were the days like i remember
filming i remember having such a blast
like being a character and like being on
set and being around but it was like it
was just
being around everybody that kind of made
me love this movie even more being a
part of it you know and making these
these relationships you know i felt like
that was kind of
i mean that was what i took away from it
the most you know man this is just
unreal
this is this is my life now so i think
that was kind of one of my my favorite
things about about film events too
how was the process for you of this film
how long did it take from you finding
out about this film to you auditioning
for it
to you to finally be on the set
mine was so wild um
so at the time i only had a manager i
had uh i had moved to la
liz i had been in l.a maybe
like a year i've been in la a year
and uh my manager got the audition and
it said on title new jersey project
and i was like alright cool whatever and
then you know i don't know how how other
actors operate whenever i get uh like a
breakdown and like the sides of you know
to audition or self tape whatever i
always look at you know who's directing
who's producing the writers kind of do
my research can see what's going on and
i saw you know alan taylor and then i
saw david chase and
larry conan
david chase oh man
this is this is a sopranos prequel and
my manager was like
yeah so i was like oh [__] but it was
funny because i was reading you know how
david is i was reading for the role of
butter that was my character's name but
so i was like all right i don't care
what it is i don't care if i die i don't
care if i don't care if like i'm only in
a scene like i don't wanna i wanna do
this so i remember i got the sides on a
tuesday
and i hit up one of my boys um and i was
like yo can you run these lines with me
like it's pretty big
yeah let's do it so we were running the
lines and we went through it it's like
three or four pages and uh i'll never
forget he was like
yeah this isn't gonna work man you sound
like biggie smalls i was like oh [__] i
was like because i didn't know you know
i don't know how to do like a mafia you
know so we watched the pilot that night
and uh watched the pilot of sopranos i
had never seen him before and i watched
the pilot and i kind of like got a feel
for it and then we ran it again
and my boy's like yes do it just like
this so i memorized it i went in the
next day and uh put it they put me on
tape um because they had sent it to la
to find
butter
and uh i read
they liked it gave me some notes i ran
it one more time and
we chatted for a second and then they
were like the best of luck and then that
was on a wednesday
and then that next week and next friday
so like you know ten days later uh they
hit up my manager and they're like hey
uh you're our guy
and so we we did that you know we did a
contract with everything and then they
were like also here's your nba
uh you're playing a young version of big
[__] i was like oh
[__] i was like this is wild this is
crazy so it happened so
so fast that those 10 days felt like
forever but i mean it happened really
really fast and then they're like all
right what's your you know what what's
your availability for you know we want
to do the table read can you come out in
march before we start filming blah blah
blah
and it just all happened like boom boom
boom boom boom so
it was it was pretty wild it was it was
kind of uh it was kind of insane how
fast it happened but the funniest part
about all of it was i started watching
surprise after i got it after i got the
audition and i think i was like halfway
through like season one maybe i had just
finished season one and mind you i'd
only been in la for a year and i only
had a manager i called my manager i'm
like hey
there's this guy in the in the show
vinnie that's still as if
i kind of look like him i was like i
want you to call them back and i want
you to see if there's a young version
big fuss i want to audition and my
manager ryan glasgow great guy just 50
year old gay man he goes
listen sweetie calm down that's not how
this works and i was just like all right
my bad my bad i bet i'll get a little
too ahead of myself and then that's why
when the news came we were like ecstatic
he was like i hope you understand
exactly what you're stepping into
because he was a huge surprise fan as
well
and
ever since then it's just been
so it was a really good process but i
mean i'm excited david
had the confidence in me to kind of to
step into this world you know
i remember when we first did our first
scene together i was looking at you and
i'm like
your excitement was contagious and
that's what i've always told people that
you know
when you get excited about like i have
to read sponsors for this podcast you
know and you have to be excited that's
what makes other people get excited
to go [__] it i need me undies
[__] it i'm gonna put a bed in tonight
with draftkings you know
excitement creates excitement and i
remember
how excited you are and i'm like you
know what
i gotta get [__] excited like this
[__] guy you know when i got the
audition
i heard about the film i called my
agents
because they're [__] sleepy you know
they'd rather keep me on the road
yeah issued a movie you know yeah so
i called them beat them up a little bit
like yeah i got to read for this you
guys [__] up with the irishman
and you [__] up with something else
you didn't get me into that i didn't
read for green book
i don't know what the [__] you guys are
doing so i'm taking control of this [__]
i want an audition for this one i'm
going to get somebody to get me an
audition for this then they sent me the
paperwork
and they're like auditioned for this
role and i remember looking at it and
for me it was looking at it and figuring
it out
i had heard about david chase's writing
for years yeah yeah you got to remember
i went to new york in 99
and i was passing out tapes to different
comedy clubs and casting directors and
my manager called me goes you got to
drop a tape off at this new show
the sopranos and i'm like i can't sing
yeah i can't [__] sing why am i going
in for the sopranos
and i forgot all about it and one night
i'm in cleveland all [__] up at the
hotel
and i turn it on the tv on and it's the
sopranos and i'm like i read for that
and it was by that time it was like
episode four or five it i didn't watch
the trailer or the pi i didn't know
nothing i was it was a [__] comic in
99 it was a whole different [__]
world you know and uh
i came to new york with no whatever of
auditioning for the sopranos or anything
and i did the new york comedy festival
and
her assistant saw me on stage
at 12 30 at night and came up to me
after my set and said
can you read the sopranos tomorrow 11
o'clock i go no i'm leaving for buffalo
she's like well you just got to make it
there i need georgine walking to see you
tomorrow yeah i auditioned for them
for gigi
the the fbi agent
and for baccalaureate didn't get any of
them and then
they contacted me to put a uh
a comedian on tape
and i didn't get that one either
and then a couple years later i got hit
up for the part of big pussy's brother
and i put it on tape and i got fired i
was shooting spider-man 2. and they
called me when i met sony going
georgine called me georgine walking
christopher walken's wife and she's like
we need you to
lay this audition down and i'm like well
you know i got to wait till i get home
and i [__] i booked it and i got
fired a lot of people don't know that
yeah that's news to me yeah for lack of
confidentiality agreement because they
said i told somebody i was auditioning
for the sopranos
oh [__] yup so that's why when
and there was a certain person that
ratted me out you know so i was like wow
you know i just
when she called me i took the hit i was
a little upset i knew i'd never get on
the sopranos and i moved on so when i
got the movie i went home and like one
the first break i had
and i'm like you know what i'm not even
mad at that rat anymore that ratted me
out because
he did me a favor
i would have done the sopranos when i
wasn't ready
yeah do you know what i'm saying
sometimes you got to be ready for
something sometimes you're going to get
a few projects
i ultimately still [__] that guy but yes
i think
i'm saying like you're gonna get a role
in the future that you're gonna call me
one day and go remember the conversation
we had on the podcast seven eight years
ago i just bumped into that situation
you're gonna shoot something that
i don't know you're not gonna feel it
you know it's funny because
since you know since we wrapped on this
and everything and you know
my career has been moving
there's been so many like and i i it's
so frustrating there's been so many like
me and one other guy
me and one of the guys and i'm like and
all of them have been really really dope
projects and it's like man i could do
this i could do that but wide range you
know i mean all over the place like one
was for you know
you know working in military one is like
a vampire one is you know
this guy was so it's all over the place
but it's always been me and one other
guy
and and one of like some of the advice i
keep getting from a lot of you know vets
is like
it'll happen when when it when it's time
it's time that's just that's how it is
out here that's how our industry works
when it's when the moment's right when
the timing's right it'll happen
i think that's
it was the same with this when i to play
a young vinny and then it was right and
then it's just it's it's gotta it's
gotta take time that's why the longevity
of it
of people's career
is and the people that make dope [__]
it's like
it was the right moment in their careers
you know so i think that's kind of why
uh it's it's giving me comfort you know
it's giving me some comfort because i'm
like [__] i wanna i wanna work i wanna
be i wanna be number one with karma you
know like i want to be that i want to do
that you know
so i think it's i think that eagerness
is kind of uh it's it's it's a little a
little bit of a little bit of a bad
thing sometimes i guess no it's natural
brother you got to be aggressive you're
in [__] l.a that's what the problem
with la is a lot of people go to la and
they're not aggressive
they're not aggressive i'm gonna be
honest with you i wasn't that aggressive
my first four or five years there and
i'm aggressive
i'm an aggressive [__] i get up
in the morning i go you know when when
mike walked in today i was putting
audition on tape i do my work you know
oh yeah but you could be aggressive and
then you could there's a certain way of
being aggressive working smarter you
know yeah and i [__] was aggressive
as [__] like you couldn't tell me no
like they told me no for the longest
yard do you know that
we don't even want you to read for it
what but
doug this is what
this is what i'm you're gonna run into
this where people are gonna go we really
like samson
but he's not gonna read for this and
you're gonna think about it you're gonna
go home smoke a joint go out one of your
friends
you're going to tell one of your actor
friends hey i wanted to read for this
and then go you'll be perfect for this
who told you no and you're like
they said they didn't want me and you go
[__] you
i'm going to hire somebody and put me on
tape for the longest yard i went and
bought extra small t-shirts
and extra small football helmets
and i put them on like a two-year-old
football helmet on my head i had a
headache for two [__] weeks
and i got a shirt that was six sizes too
small for me and my gut was huge the
shirt was ripping as i was doing the
audition i could hear the shirt going
but i didn't give a [__] i'm taking this
role because the roles were gonna be
offered to tony saragusa or vinnie
pastor
both of them sweethearts both of them
great guys
but the one thing both of them aren't
are comedians
so how are you gonna order how are you
gonna give two roles
in a comedic film to two guys that are
not comics they're great actors in their
own perspective right sarah goose is a
funny dude you know he was with football
with the [__] whatever
but
i and when i let that settle
i put it on tape and i nailed that movie
because you're not going to tell a guy
like me no
that's never going to [__] happen not
on my [__] clock
and that's the that was the difference
of aggressiveness that was the
difference
how long have you been like
what number was that movie wise for me
had to be like number 25
i'm saying like like for like a big role
like i mean
that's how deep into your career was
that
23 years later
i started acting in 97 so
it took me three years to get my feet
under me i did a couple projects and
then for like four years three years
i just did college films
yeah
i just did all those ucla usc films that
nobody would ever gonna [__] watch
nobody's ever gonna see those three
people
the director's group
now we got to do some homework we got to
fight
yeah the director's grandmother his
mother
and his uncle is going to watch the
movie ain't nobody else going to watch
that movie you know what i'm saying
let's be honest with yourself so no
matter how badly i [__] up ain't nobody
going to see it
so that was my mentality but at the same
time
i was auditioning for big shows
okay you know [__] like that on nbc abc
and nothing was happening and then one
day it clicked
and i booked a four episode art kind of
show and the first two shows
i was trying to get you know i was
waking up out of my fog and then when i
finally woke up
my the episodes i was really good at
were seven and eight guess when the show
got cancelled
six
you got it
you got a career as a [__] path
reader palmerita [__] episode six
how do you tell that to your friends
like my career is on fire
i got four episodes on nbc the first two
you're just like a mutt you you don't
know what you're doing you're just like
see you know whatever the [__] line
is then after that you go home and
you're like why am i acting that way i
gotta act more like a [__] and now
you go and you do a breakthrough you do
your [__] you know steve mcqueen and
the [__] show gets cancelled
episode six and you're like yeah that's
great
that's great and i would have been mad
as [__] dog and that happened to me
eight times do you know what i'm saying
like that's part of the [__] drama
that's part of the tears you know how
about i'm on [__] my name is earl i
got four rolls recurring he pulls me
over after the last episode for the
christmas break and he goes dawg you're
doing all of them next year in the
prison so i'm going to be on nbc during
pilot season that's [__] tremendous
that's like stealing you just write your
own [__]
you know what i'm saying
what happened there's a [__] writer
strike january 12th no [__] episode
that's it no pilot no [__] greg
garcia no nobody so
these are the part these are the little
things in the business that [__] with
you the best is when you audition for
something how about these when you're
auditioning december 3rd
remember there used to be pre-reads you
know that right i mean i've heard of it
yeah they used to be pre-reads where you
went in there the [__] didn't
talk to you like a [__] red red with
you
some guy with like a eye patch on red
with you and then if you got past him
then you read with the [__] casting
director
then if you got past the casting
director you got a call back
you came in and you had a call back for
the thing and then they called you again
and you had to read with the other
actors
that were selected
and then they called you again
and do the word lines backwards
you know
and then [__] oh my god they would
put you through hell when i first got to
l.a
it was a pre-read first in a room with
the people with bad breath
you know those people with ugly head
shots that they got like their
grandparents to take a picture of them
you know with like sunglasses on and
[__]
it's them oh it was a nightmare it was a
nightmare and then so now you go for an
audition december 3rd this is for the
people at home i just want to give you a
little [__] a little taste of our
lies next time you see angelina jolie
with the eight [__] kids
think of what she had to put up with to
get those eight [__] kids so you read
for something december 1st okay
december 3rd you get the call back for
the direct casting director then
december 8th you get the call back for
the [__] producers right and they
love you now they start mixing and
matching let's go back to four brothers
for me remember that movie four brothers
one of my favorites marky wahlberg when
i did the longest yard they called me
right into four brothers for 18 weeks
they mixed and matched me marky whatever
and at the end of the day i lost a role
to a black guy that was a star so what
the [__] did you put me through all this
[__] for 18 weeks of meeting people
talking to foreigners black people go to
detroit yeah they spent ten thousand not
to hire me unfucking believable
it's the truth
ten thousand not to hire me you're going
there it's i've had people tell me
they've read me 18 times they were like
this role is you and all of a sudden
they tell you you didn't get it and you
look at the role and they give it to a
black [__] now i ain't got nothing
against black midgets but where the [__]
did they say black [__] on the
breakdown they weren't even looking for
a black [__] when this [__] show
was [__] written all of a sudden
during my [__] audition is when they
decided i'm the black [__] [__] so
now i got to sit there and watch this tv
show i almost got with a black [__]
[__] again i got nothing against black
midgets i'm just saying this is the life
of a [__] actor so when you see me on
the many saints and you see samson on
the [__] screen and you're like
that's so lucky not really
we've been through health to get here
you understand me
i had to go to delaware and get breed
done by the [__] covenant in delaware
to get here so
and you and on top of all this you got
to stay positive
yes like you gotta go today's my lucky
day [__] i'm gonna rub my balls
and sniff my fingers that's that's how
in the process of all this people [__]
with you telling you to get the best is
when you read the whole month of
december
because the project starts january 24th
and then you go read the last time
december 19th and you call your agent
december 20th and go what's my status
with the show and they go i don't know
they're going to contact you after the
[__] winter break
you have no [__] idea what it's like
[__] you and your [__] driving job at
uber let me tell you something you don't
know what it's like christmas you break
the tree they did that to me three years
in a row i just lit the tree on fire
[__] christmas be cool
get shorty and there was another tv show
that put me on a oh
the movie would uh when [__] ving
rhames fought
uh
spade whatever blade whatever his name
is
wesley snipes
it was supposed to be when mike tyson
went to prison and some guy beat him up
in prison
there's a movie that it's a walter hill
film
doesn't really matter yeah that was one
of those [__] that walter hill
came to see me at the comedy store
he had me in there every day reading
with another guy back in [__] fort
and all of a sudden december 18th he's
like i'll let you know january 10th what
i'll light your [__] christmas tree
on fire walter hill how are you gonna
leave me hanging out you can't even open
up a present without crying you [__]
you're looking at the sweater from
grandma going i wish i would have got
that [__] roll
it's a [__] nightmare i had something
so similar and i had been in l.a
had it been
four months
so i had been in la
and i got i got the audition
and i went
boom and they loved it my back for a
call back and then i had a second call
back and they were like hey
it was for like a big amc show
all right that's what you know for a
season they already had
eight twelve episodes
and i was like man here it is like let's
go
oh that's a lot not four months i had
been in here probably like eight months
so i was i was like all right let's get
it i'm like i'm
i'm brand new to this i was like i'm
my career is i'm here like i didn't have
to wait nothing bro and then i'm
learning it as i go so it has the
initial audition was before thanksgiving
so then i had to wait like a whole two
weeks to get the call back and i got the
call back and then i went two more and
then like i had another one
i think it was like yeah like december
like 15 16 17 and then right in there
and they're like dude yeah you already
got are you available yeah you're
availability like you know you're on the
veil so we're available for from january
to june right like everything's cool i'm
like yes like let's do this like i'm
ready i'm ready
okay well we'll contact you after the
holiday break
you want me to go home and tell my
parents after i just moved to l.a
they're like
i haven't you know and i'm excited i'm
getting everybody so that's when i
learned i was like all right so don't
say [__] don't expect [__] because like
you got it oh man it was the worst and
then i ended up
losing it
and they told us i think and that they
told us like
it says like january 12th so from that
whole month i'm like this is mine it's
mine like i'm going i'm going up north
like i'm filming in the northeast like i
was like hey that's my grandparents we
have family up there right like i could
go see them like i was like it was done
like it was like oh we love you you're
our guy let's lock this contract in da
da da da
da
but the funniest part about it
what do you think about is fast forward
so that was like you know before
thanksgiving is 10. so fast for like
another two months month and a half
i got this audition for sopranos for
many sense
so how that book did you know i mean
like you know everything happens for a
reason but i was
that's when i was really excited i was
like oh man i'm gonna be on this show
series regular like i'm like four on
call she like this this is my life's
about to change
nope and then i i was like mad you know
for a little bit and then all of a
sudden
i get uh i get this audition for this
movie so
worked out in the end
what are you expecting tonight my friend
what are you expecting to see and i i
mean you saw it right yeah you come from
sorry i saw it i mean i'm excited for
people to see it i'm excited for it to
finally be out i'm excited for it
you know
mostly
tonight i i'm i'm excited for people to
see michael you know what i mean
there's been so much um
so much hype so much expectation you
know and so much you know i don't know
what you know i don't know the word for
because i can't imagine what it's going
to you know i mean that's one of my best
friends my brother i love that kid you
know i love him so much and i just can't
wait for the world to see tonight
not only is he
a great person and a great actor but
like
he meets the hype you know i mean he
really does and i'm excited for the
world to see this and then for his
career to just kind of move
because i mean let's keep it real his
father has been one of the greatest
actors
that's just i mean that's just a fact
and i you know it's it's i always
compare him and i talk about all the
time we always kind of compare things to
sports you know you know i grew football
i grew up playing football
and so i kind of relate everything to
that
and it's uh
it's like you know being the son of
you know a
hall of famer you know you kind of got
to live up to that hype you know
you know any sport lebron's kids like
they're playing basketball you got to
live up you know the the father never
wants that for them and you know the
world is kind of like if you but it's
like it's that's just inevitable you're
going to have to live up to the hype
and uh
michael does a phenomenal job and i'm
just i'm excited for the world to see it
um
alessandro is
i know he's he's
he's amazing in this i'm ready for the
world for him to just not his career
that just
boom michaela
and everyone just did a phenomenal job
i'm just i'm excited for soprano fans
and
new and and new people to come and watch
this and then fall in love with
all the i think that's kind of the whole
vibe of that
i can't wait for because
i mean
just sitting down watching the show i
was just like damn i can't believe i
called myself an actor and i had never
seen
one of the greatest shows of all time
you know what i mean so i i'm i'm
excited just to be a part of this whole
entire universe in itself you know you
know for me man i'm from jersey
and
i can't imagine what it must mean for
you oh
for me it's like uh
i'm from jersey
i'm very proud to be from jersey i'm
very proud that i grew up here i made
the most of my childhood i rob trains i
[__] rob jewelry stores
i had a great [__] life i almost
drowned in seaside i almost died at
seaside park kind of hit an acid on the
[__]
on the water slides you know
i [__] i took advantage of this state
uh
everything it had you know and
number two the state was the second
highest population of cubans
behind miami and they [__] you know
i
i listen i when i came from cuba i went
right to new york city and i went to
grammar school in new york city
but my foot was always in jersey
you know like i used to get mad at
people when they talk [__] about jersey
you know yeah and i told david chase one
night at like three in the morning we
were shooting one of those long [__]
nights
you know he asked me something about the
sopranos and i go listen man
you
did something that bruce springsteen and
bon jovi couldn't even do you know
people loved her
yeah and people love bruce springsteen
yeah but i still remember in 1998
signing with an agent
and she said give me your bio and when i
wrote northberg in new jersey she called
me and she goes you got to take new
jersey off
people don't like it if you're from
jersey so she filled in
hell's kitchen
and one of my friends saw it when he
came to see me and he's like dog what
the [__] can i go you don't understand
you don't understand that these [__]
people don't like
jersey really and within two years
the sopranos had taken that whole bad
taste out of people's mouths
just flipped it around now jersey's a
hot spot even the [__] jersey shore
yeah tv show couldn't make people
really see what jersey was for you know
when you see the sopranos i mean even in
our movie when you see the sopranos
they inflict catholicism in there
you know something that you never do
with a show
but in jersey catholicism is so big
you're either a jew or a [__]
catholic there's no in between you know
i'm a lutheran no you're not not in
jersey you're not unless you live down
there with the martians down with that
[__]
that [__] pass whatever exit four those
people that have like clear eyes they're
albinos and [__] you know there's some
weird [__] in jersey monaco new
jersey got the ugliest people you've
ever seen in your life everybody got a
big head they walk weird when you're in
monarchy it's like the twilight zone the
only good thing about monaki is segovia
restaurant i have to take you there how
long you stayed in town for
um you know i don't have a flight back
okay the
27th and the 29th they are doing
movies in eatontown and mammoth
okay and they want all of us to go down
there
me you michael gandolfini it's the
wall something f uh
film festival oh okay yeah so michael
agreed to it he called me again this
morning the guy he's like yeah we spoke
a few weeks ago
you know i he sent an invitation to
allen and david chase what are their
chances of going into the heart of new
jersey so yeah i want to know who's
going to stick around for a few days
they're doing one monday night the 20s
yeah it's monday
at 6 15
in jersey and wednesday at 6 15 in
jersey
it's the art house film festival
oh yeah so they want us to do some type
of q a so it would be you me we'll see
if alessandro wants we'll bring
everybody i don't give a [__]
we're gonna get some dinner at the
osteria
i'm eight i'll take it to the [__]
osteria and we'll get some [__] uh
your world i just live in it okay that's
it [__] it so i'll see you tonight ready
to go you want to smoke some reefer
tonight what are we doing tonight no
it's funny it's funny because when all
my friends find out that you know i was
working with you and stuff they're like
you know what like is he really sleepy
smoking then i said i and i have one of
my funniest stories was
when i'm sitting at a table
and uh it was like i don't know i think
they were doing a different setup or
something i was sitting there and i just
remember like hey
i want to see the demo
and like you pulled out you had like uh
what was it like little edible things it
was like 200 milligrams of a thing i
remember you said you like you snuck it
to like your cousin or something was
passed out in the bushes like for like
three hours
and everyone's like are you kidding me i
said nah i was like he just i'm like
he's
his tolerance is unreal i'm like this
guy is just like i was like i can't
smoke with him i can't hang out with him
i can't be around him when he's smoking
weed because i i know i'll just be
i'll be slumped i was like there's no
way there's no i might hit a joint with
you but yeah bro i can't
keep it over there bro you keep it over
there
yeah we'll bring some edibles tomorrow
night i only got 100 milligrams now
so we go you got to go you know what i'm
saying it's not like a 10 where you you
put your foot in like a cuban you're
like when you land in the united states
you got a foot in the ocean you got a
foot on the beach and you're an american
now we don't work that way we put both
[__] feet in
you don't know
we [__] what was that what happened
that day remember we were filming and
then we rapped
and you and i went back to the trailers
and we were waiting for our ride
and i remember one of the pas came up
and unwrapped me
oh i was pissed
i will never forget we're just sitting
there waiting for our cars you smoking
the joy and you just like
day off changed out of the soup got the
sweats on
sitting outside each other just smoking
joey i'm so sorry we're gonna have to
unwrap you
i just looked that up like are you
[__] serious
and i'll tell you out of all the nights
like sometimes at night i smoke pot and
i don't get high
like because i burned the [__] candle
on both edges you know so
but on that particular night whatever
was in that joint toenail polish
whatever the [__] was in there [__] me
up
and she came back to me she's like you
gotta re-wrap it was like two in the
morning it was late it was late yeah
yeah i'm like what the [__] i'm on the
corner in brooklyn
there's not a soul out i'm by myself
waiting for an uber this little poor
little hindu girl came that was just the
cutest thing in the world
and they're like nah you gotta go
[__] unwrap and i remember going i am
so [__] stoned
and i had to take my clothes off put the
heavy artillery on the vest the white
shirt the tie the jewelry
and i walked in and i remember that i
wasn't mad as much as uh
it was funny to me because i walked in
and all of them were like like a little
prepared for me to go off or whatever
and i was like what the [__] just
happened
i go this is the most unprofessional
thing i've ever seen in my life do you
know that alan just looked at me he's a
sweetheart him and the other guy that i
used to call the arab or whatever the
[__] swahili guy
i'm like
i'm like you are out of your [__]
mind and so are you i go this is the
most unprofessional thing i've ever seen
you for calling me back after two hours
of being wrapped and me for being as
stoned as a [__] tommy chang i was
high as [__] i didn't have no lines they
just wanted me to stand there
it was somebody else's [__] uh scene
what are you gonna [__] do you know
what i'm saying i'm excited for tonight
i'm excited
to see what happens with you and your
career you're a young guy
and you got all the tools brother i wish
you all the [__] luck in the world
and hopefully tonight it'll be the
beginning of a [__] great [__]
career so i wish you
all the luck i can't wait to give you a
hug tonight
and sneak and edible in your soda
and
by the end of the movie you'll be
sitting there
what prequel
sen tell my girl i said hello and she
coming to the premiere yeah yeah she'll
be like okay send it tell her i'll see
them tonight
tip top magu ready to go and then we're
going to the after party
then there's an after after after party
i'm at all of them i'm at all of them
that one is at a chinese [__] opium
den in [__] chinatown i'm taking you
to okay maybe i'll skip that one but
other than nah we'll go into the opium
then they give you egg rolls and opium
you can't [__] lose you understand me
a chinese guy rubs your feet you'll feel
like [__] brand new
i love it i love it i'll see you tonight
brother thank you for coming on the
joint
thank you
don't forget to follow samson on twitter
instagram wherever the [__] he's from
you're gonna love him he's tremendous
it's gonna be a great time tonight
take care samson love you
all right that was a fun interview uh
as you could tell we're all excited
we're all [__] giggly about tonight
uh
i just got a call earlier they're doing
a dinner if i wanted to go to dinner
beforehand you know this is going to be
great tonight i appreciate all you guys
uh encouragement i appreciate everything
you did for me
during this time you guys know that this
is a special uh i'm excited about
tonight i'm excited about this project
i'm excited about living in [__] new
jersey i'm excited about being back as a
[__] hold so
i love you [__] don't forget
we got great fights this week the return
of nick diaz against [__] robbie
lawler
we got [__] shinenko we got draftking
we got a bunch of [__] going on
i love you [__] have a great
weekend i want to thank samson for
coming on the joint and i want to thank
you guys for always having my
[__] back
uh can't wait to tell you about the
premiere and how it went i'll see you
guys monday morning
tip top [__] magoo ready to go
the last week of [__] september we're
on to the [__] winter by the way
happy spring it's spring today
watch your [__] [__] [__] i
love you stay black now for a word for
my [__] sponsors
all right i want to thank my man samson
malcolm
i don't know
i don't know what his last name is he's
a great [__] kid i love him to death
and he really helped me out through the
movie uh follow his career follow him on
twitter
instagram facebook great [__] kid and
do not forget to get your tickets early
for the many saints in newark before we
leave
from the heart of new jersey the joint
is brought to you by giraffe kings it's
the ufc this weekend as a matter of fact
it's ufc
266 volnowski against ortega and diaz
against robbie lawler tremendous they
got a great prelim card listen draft
king sportsbook it's the official sports
betting partner ufc and they have a
knockout offer for you this weekend you
ready
they're offering you you better dial in
any fight before the main event
whether you want to lose you get 103
dollars in free bets instantly did you
hear what i just said better dollar on
any ufc 266 fight
and draftking sportsbook app will give
you 150 and free bets
ufc ain't for you don't worry about it
draftkings has a sports book that has
you covered with great odds and
promotions on football
baseball college football golf and more
draftkings are safe secure reliable plus
they have a casino that will knock your
socks off the best part is you can
withdraw your cash whenever you want
don't miss the action on ufc 266 and
draftking sportsbook app the official
betting partner of the ufc
download the draftking sportsbook app
right now today
use promo code joey to receive 150 and
free bets
instantly when you place a dollar bet
on ufc 266 that's promo code joey to
receive 150 and free bets instantly for
a limited time only at draftkings you
got to be 21 older new jersey indiana
pennsylvania colorado if it's legal in
your state
draftkings
could work for you download the
draftking sportsbook app right now use
promo code joey and get this [__]
party started you better dial in any
fight you got 150 and free bets
got a gambling problem called 1-800
gambler if you're in indiana
call 1-809 with it but if you're
straight download the draftking
sportsbook app and let's win some
[__] guitars
football baseball and the ufc this
weekend the joint is also brought to you
by
zip recruiter forbes magazine says jim's
hotels and salons
are set to go on an epic hiring stream
in the next few months
millions of jobs will need to be filled
as businesses keep reopening how do you
hire people fast
zip recruiter try it for free at
ziprecruiter.com
joey you got none to lose people haven't
worked in months they're ready to go
back and all the good people are ready
to go back
here's the difference with zip recruiter
you're not just posting a job and
waiting for some joe schmoe to come in
zip recruiter has the best technology
available that finds the best people for
your job and helps you get to them it
tells you who's the most qualified and
invites them to apply
you get two and a half times more
candidates this way right now today you
can try ziprecruiter for free
at ziprecruiter.com
joey that's ziprecruit.com
joey j-o-e-y
zip recruiter the smartest
way to hire the joint is also brought to
you by
stamps.com
my wife and i have been with stamps.com
for close to 10 years
she loves it she hasn't been to the post
office in years when we got a mail
something she just calls the post office
puts a little arrow up on the box and
the guy takes it to go no drama and we
save an hour by not going to a post
office stop wasting it on trips to the
post office stance.com makes your life
easy and it's easy to use you ship right
from your computer in your home save
time and money with stamps.com you can
send letters and packages for less with
discounted rates from usps ups and more
since 1998 stamps.com has been an
indispensable tool for nearly one
million businesses small
and large they bring the services of the
u.s postal service
and ups right
to your door if you're in an office
sending invoices and have a side office
side hustle
or if you have a full-blown warehouse
shipping out all this stamps.com
will make your life easier all you need
is a computer and a printer no special
supplies or equipment required
stamps.com will take care of you with
anything you can print any official
postage on any letter any package
anywhere you want to ship
with stamps.com you get exclusive
discounts and postage on shipping
from ups and you sps if you're not with
stamps.com you're slipping save time and
money with stamps.com there's zero risk
no risk nada use promo code joey to get
a special offer that includes you ready
for this a four week trial
free postage and a digital scale no
learn no long term commitments or
contracts just go to stamps.com click on
the microphone at the top of the home
page and type in joey that stamps.com
promo code joey
never go to a post office again
i want to thank stamps.com i want to
thank draftkings i want to thank zip
recruiter i want to thank cbd lion for
making this week complete but most
importantly i want to thank you guys
for being savages and for always having
my back
have a great weekend i love you guys
we'll see you monday the 30th tip top
[__] magoo
have a great weekend savages